what's your favorite chapter in the book
like one that you're especially proud of
or a topic that just really gets you
going you know though one of my
favorites is the one in the flaw because
I think the flaw is so important I think
it may be the longest chapter in the
book and I loved writing about it and it
just is an area that it's like the one
tool I can give a new writer right off
the bat that will make a huge
improvement and a lot of writers don't
know anything about it and it really is
the most fundamental you know important
thing for story building to realize the
importance of having a really strong
flaw and it's a rookie mistake sometimes
I see the characters they didn't even
know that their protagonist was supposed
to have a flaw right we're not used to
thinking about our heroes as having
flaws they're not flawed everybody else
is the one that's screwed up yeah but if
everyone else is screwed up then you're
making your protagonist just a victim of
these things happening right it's a
deeper level to start thinking about
what is what is the flaw in them that is
actually making their problem worse and
I that's one of the favor my favorite
things to talk about with writers to
explore it's just one of the most
fundamental things to understanding who
the character is is that one single
thing the flaw so it's the longest
chapter ice I try to explore it the most
and and I think it's one of the most
things that will give writers the most
yield as far as understanding story and
characters to really give some thought
as to what is my protagonist central
flaw well there's certain movies you
recommend that they watch that show an
especially flawed character oh I love
movies with a lot character that's
leaving Las Vegas III still I would I
haven't nutshell that movie but I would
argue that right so would be a tragedy I
would argue argue that it didn't have a
satisfying enough second act up turn but
I'd have to go back and look at it to
see I like movies that are more
are technically comedies so structurally
that means they have a happy ending but
it have really flawed characters because
I think it's it's it's really easy and
not very interesting to have likeable
characters but how much more delicious
is it to have a really unlikable
character right and then by the end you
get us cheering for them that's really
good writing so I'll point out one movie
that I love for that reasons the movie
the verdict
it's a Paul Newman movie prime and this
guy you've heard of he's a lawyer
you've heard of ambulance chasers oh yes
this guy is a hearse chaser oh wow he
crashes funerals
under the pretense of having known the
deceased he and he just finds them in
obituaries he preys on these
unsuspecting widows trying to get work
he's such a hardcore alcoholic that he
can't pick up his morning shot with his
donut without the shakes he's got a lean
over at one point to drink that at one
point he punches a woman in the face
characters unbelievably unlikable but by
the end of the movie we're rooting for
the sky hmm that's amazing screenwriting
that's amazing screenwriting right well
you can get us to care about this guy
and we do we really care that's that's
the the depth of how great the
screenwriting is and how great the
performance too is one of Paul Newman's
greatest performances so I love
unlikable characters that you can get us
to like by the end that tells you
something
so really flawed characters like that I
another interesting movie to me a more
recent example is flight okay and for me
what was really interesting so we're
very L call it character make good
characters up they do nicely clog
characters they're great that's a great
flaw and by the way alcoholism is not a
flaw for our purposes you want to find
what's the under lying flaw so it's
gonna be different for different
alcoholics the the alcoholic and the
verdict he has no sense of self-worth in
flight this alcoholic has this
incredible sense of entitlement right so
it's gonna be different you want to dig
deeper find out what is the the flaw
underneath it and what I love about
flight it has the most it's a wonderful
example of an incredibly surprising yet
satisfying third act and I'm not I guess
I don't want to give spoilers if someone
hasn't seen it but I'll just say that
the character the protagonist is in we
think he's gonna get we want him to get
off scot-free because we are rooting for
this guy even though he's an alcoholic
and he's got a lot of issues and we kind
of know he shouldn't go free and things
don't go the best possible way but it's
incredibly surprising and satisfying and
so it's it has a really unusual
particular like a Hollywood movie I
think a really unusual third act and
ending where we have a character under
outward circumstances you wouldn't say
on paper that sounded like a happy
ending
and yet he's the happiest we've seen him
the whole movie even though things
didn't go his way
you